[Music]
the first stock cars were souped up
family sedans
but today they're custom built for the
racetrack
each car body must match the contours of
templates set by nascar
the national association of stock car
auto racing
[Music]
on the race track the shape of a car can
give it an aerodynamic edge over the
competition
so in nascar races car bodies must have
uniform curves
the regulations put the focus on driver
skill and make the race a fair one
they mold some of the car's body parts
from a carbon fiber and kevlar material
first a technician applies a release
agent to a mold for the car's front end
then he sprays a paint undercoat into it
this undercoat will eventually transfer
to the completed panel
[Music]
a computerized cutter slices the carbon
fiber and kevlar fabric into strips
it produces 22 pieces each one
cut to fit a different section of the
mold the technician rolls epoxy resin
onto the fabric
one strip at a time once the strip has
been completely coated
he transfers it to the mold
he tucks the fabric into the contours
and smooths out any big wrinkles
he layers the strips three deep in a
criss-cross configuration
for structural integrity
a co-worker covers the carbon fiber with
perforated plastic
[Music]
they add layers of absorbent polyester
and thick plastic
which they glue to the edge of the mold
they insert a fitting and connect a
vacuum which sucks out air and excess
epoxy resin
[Music]
the polyester material soaks up the
resin as it flows through the holes in
the first plastic layer
this both smooths and compacts the
carbon fiber layers
then it's into a hot oven to bake for
three hours
this activates the epoxy and combines
the layers of carbon fiber and kevlar
fabric
an employee removes the completed stock
car panel and inspects it
then it's over to a waste station at
just under eight pounds
the part is lightweight yet virtually
shatter proof
[Music]
meanwhile at another factory work begins
on the stock car chassis
they build it from square steel tubing
that's super strong
an employee welds the pieces together to
create a support structure for the car
at the next station a worker forces
narrow steel tubing against a spiral bit
to carve notches in it
this tubing is for the roll cage the
structure that protects the driver if
there's an accident
the notches will help form better joints
he grinds the rough edges creating a
smooth surface
to weld the tube to the rest of the roll
cage
[Music]
once complete the team transfers the
roll cage to the main frame of the
chassis
they tack weld it before doing the final
welds
the next part is called the rear clip it
holds the fuel tank and has mounts for
the rear suspension
with the car framework now complete a
technician scans it using a digital
measuring probe
the scan confirms that the dimensions
are correct
they now assemble the various steel and
carbon fiber body parts to the stock car
framework
they measure the completed car body by
laying template grids on it
the biggest one sits over the center of
the car
they pull a gauge through the gaps
between the templates and the car body
[Music]
the gap cannot exceed the tolerances set
by nascar
they often must tweak the shape of the
body part to meet regulations
once the car has been painted they apply
headlight decals where the real ones
usually are
real headlights would add too much
weight and pose a safety risk if they
shattered
[Music]
it's taken three weeks of intensive work
but this stock car body is now
ready for the mechanics things are about
to pick up speed